the short answer is no yo what is up
everybody mad Luigi here and today we're
going to be talking about a question on
a lot of people's mind as Dark Souls 3
is about over is there going to be a
Dark Souls for there going to be more
Dark Souls content in the future the
short answers are said in the beginning
is no but the actual answer is a fit
more complex than that and just to say
this video is a bit more casual than my
normal videos I'm going off script and
just a little bit of PvP footage so hope
you guys enjoy it but getting into the
topic so why do I think there's not
going to be dark souls for I don't
because the director of Dark Souls that
atacama Miyazaki has said as of Dark
Souls 3 the Ring City the Dark Soul
serie is complete they don't have any
further future plans to make more Dark
Souls content so we aren't going to get
an actual successor to Dark Souls namely
Dark Souls for that doesn't seem to be
happening at all it seems that really
this is the last proper Dark Souls but I
don't think we have to fret too much as
I do think we're going to get more Dark
Souls like content in the future
Miyazaki also said this that the team
from software is currently working on a
number of games that should be
interesting they're not concerned about
whether they resemble Dark Souls or not
now I think this gives credence to the
idea that we'll have more Dark Souls
content maybe in somewhat similar sense
to blood-borne because when asked about
the difficulty in Dark Souls music he
gave a similar answer he said that the
games aren't meant to be hard they're
not trying to make them hard so you just
end up being hard as a result of the
type of game that From Software wants to
make so if we apply that logic to this
statement that they're not concerned
about whether they make a game that
resemble Dark Soul enough that would
lend credence to the fact that they're
not trying to make a game that these
Dark Souls like or successor to Dark
Souls but because they're so developed
at making Dark Souls like games they
have so much practice at it or so
good at it that's their comfort zone we
can expect some form of dark to light
content in the future obviously there is
going to be a different setting it's
going to be a different universe new
characters new world building all of
that however I do think it's safe to say
that of the next three games that from
software is working on or maybe even in
the future past those three games that
we're going to get some content that
scratches the itch the Dark Soul scratch
with the gameplay focused game that is
pretty challenging and rewards you for
taking note of your surroundings being
keen to detail like we've gotten from
Demon Souls Dark Souls 1 2 and 3 and
blood-borne I do think the next Dark
Soul game or I guess I shouldn't call
the next Dark Souls game the next the
next cup of games that from software is
going to put out I do think in that
there will be a game similar to
blood-borne not necessarily specifically
blood-borne but the idea of blood-borne
that a games similar to souls slightly
different but the same main focus but in
a new setting so that the from software
team can explore new characters new
settings new everything
tests the waters for new things so I do
think that we'll get another dark soul s
game but that it's not going to be
literally Dark Souls for some more
possible proof of that is how much we
take the symbolism in the painter and
the painting that she is painting in my
previous lore videos I've talked about
the painter and the end of the dlc the
ring city though is spoilers if you
haven't beaten it but at the end of the
ring city we give the painter the dark
soul and she says she's going to paint a
new world from the dark soul and it's
going to be dark and gentle and cold and
also what I'm thinking is that the
painting and I said this in the previous
video kind of represents from software's
new game it's going to be based on
something old the Dark Souls but it's
going to be completely new it's not
going to have any of the same elements
as the old thing the new painting in
and of dartsville three the ring city
seems to be something that won't have
all the issues at the current world of
Dark Souls has like the first flame the
fire fading the cycles all that I think
it's going to be separate from that and
symbolically this could be from
software's new game in which everything
is different but it's based on the same
and the only key part that's really
returning is the player because like the
painter names her new painted world
after the player this would be from
software saying as I kind of already
said that they're going to be making a
new game based on their old game Dark
Souls so there will be more Dark Souls
like content but the only real key
factor that's the exact same is going to
be us the players since I do think most
of us that have enjoyed the souls series
is definitely going to check out be on
the lookout for from software's new
content so we are hoping for at least
I'm necessarily expecting something that
filled the niche niche that Dark Souls 3
Dark Souls 1 Dark Souls 2 and
blood-borne and Demon Souls built so
that's the majority of my ideas about
the future of Dark Souls Dark Souls for
quote-unquote not really Dark Souls for
but something like it let me know what
you guys think about Dark Souls 4 or the
future of fromsoftware in the comments
below for all you guys that want more
lore I will be posting a new law rich
video later this week
it'll be a video talking about how Dark
Souls 3 tells a story and we're going to
be looking at some lore in the ring city
that I haven't looked at yet to kind of
explain show display how fromsoftware
tells a story through Dark Souls 3 and
by extension the other Dark Souls
blood-borne I am really excited for that
video that's going to be a more
traditional prepared video unlike this
more ad-lib video but um yeah some guys
if you like this different style I don't
do a lot of these ad-lib videos anymore
I used to do a good amount when I did
other content maybe I'll do more of
these you guys liked them it is a bit
easier since I don't need to make a big
script I don't need to prepare a lot of
specific footage I'm kind of just
talking about whatever comes up online
that's about it thank you guys for
watching make sure you set my Twitter
and peace out